E
TICKETED WERE HOMELESS, MOST
LIKELY RIDING STOLEN BIKES,
WHICH A COP AT THE MOMENT THAT
THEY GAVE OUT THE TICKET.
NEVERTHELESS, IT WAS ENOUGH FOR
THE WHOLE KING  COUNTY BOARD OF
HEALTH BY A VOTE OF 11-2 TO
REPEAL THE LAW BECAUSE THEY SAY
THE RESEARCH CITED THAT "RACISM
AND ENFORCEMENT CAME AS A RESULT
OF THAT.
THE RESEARCH DOESN'T ACTUALLY
SHOW DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETED
ANYBODY.
IT DOESN'T SAY WHY THE NUMBERS
ARE AND IT DOESN'T SAY THAT
GETTING A PASS FOR IT.
THEY MAKE UP THE MAJORITY OF THE
TICKETS AND ALL IT SHOWS AS
BLACK CYCLIST IN SEATTLE HAPPEN
TO WEAR HELMETS AS MUCH AS THE
WHITE BICYCLIST.
THAT IS ALL IT SHOWS.
WHITES WERE TICKETED, BY THE WAY
TEN TIMES MORE OFTEN -- IF THIS
WAS INTENDED TO BE A LAW, TO
YOUR POINT, GO AHEAD AND OPPOSE
THIS LAW FOR LEGITIMATE REASONS
AND FOCUS ON PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IS A LEGITIMATE ARGUMENT
BUT THE LAW IS ABSURD SO APPLY
IT IN THIS WAY.
THE MAJORITY OF GANG MEMBERS IN
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON ARE
BLACK AND LATINO PEER THAT MEANS
ARRESTS ASSOCIATED WITH GANG
VIOLENCE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT BLACKS AND LATINOS.
SO, GET READY FOR ENFORCEMENTS,
GOING AFTER THE LEADERS BECAUSE
NO, COURSE IT IS OBSERVED.
>> Tucker: WHY ALL THIS
SELF-HATRED COME, THE BOTTOML